can I raise a grocery store Lobster to
be a pet mhm 18 million views this
thumbnail in the beginning the Leon the
lobster you saw that giant rubber band
on the claw like oh that is a grocery
store lobster right and then um you see
like when he snaps it off you see like
discoloration barass claw but then over
time you're like oh look at his claw
like it looks healthy again he's
actually moving it I eat lobster and uh
I love Lobster but now I'm like I'm
questioning my decisions I'm thinking
about the emotions of the lobster had
that impact on people I'm like that
Lobster is a person like if you watch
any of those Leon the lobster videos
it's like terrible quality but you could
edit that way better didn't matter cuz
the title was